we can speak now - Jamie Margolin
founder of the student-led zero-hour
movement which aims to train young
people and promote young climate change
activists she joins us live from Seattle
hello to you Jamie you started
campaigning on climate change at the age
of fourteen I wonder what was the
trigger for you what was it that made
you think I need to stop I need to do
something to change this well for my
generation there has never been a time
in my life where climate change wasn't
looming over me there was never been a
time in my life where it wasn't
dictating every decision that I made
because as a young person we're
constantly being asked to plan our
future what are you going to be when you
grow up what do you want to do and it's
very hard to plan for that in an
environment and a planet that you don't
know if it's gonna be livable so around
when I was 14 years old is when the 2016
election results came in and Donald
Trump was elected president and that was
kind of the final straw for me to take
action because now we have a full-blown
climate denier and a majority in the
United States government that even
denies the facts of this issue so for me
it's always been urgent to act on
climate change but the catalyst was
really the 2016 election that was just
like you know what my leaders are
putting profits over my life they'd
rather line their money lined their
pockets with the money of the fossil
fuel industry then make sure that their
children can breathe yes you say you
live in a country where the president
has ripped up climate change policy
vowed to pull out of the Paris agreement
do you feel that you're fighting a
losing battle there well there's no
choice but to fight this battle it's as
if there's a ticking time bomb that
needs to be stopped and there's not a
very high chance of us stopping it but
we have to stop it or at least try
because otherwise it's going to blow up
in our faces and destroy everything and
so for me I it's not a matter of you
can't really weigh the odds too much
when you're fighting for survival you
just have to you just have to fight for
your generation survival I don't really
have anything to plan forward to live
for if the earth that I'm living on can
sustained civilization as we know it
today and right now maybe the president
and the highest office is our denying
climate change but there's so much
grassroots work being done like with my
organization and through our there are
so many young people taking action
there are so many organizations and
local governments that are determined to
take action that we just have to fight
it by any means necessary and through
all the angles that we can with zero
hour we do mobilizations we're
organizing a Youth Climate Action summit
in Miami Florida this summer we do
marches we also tackle I also tackle
this from the legal perspective I'm on a
lawsuit suing my state for better
climate laws and so you you just have to
attack this issue by Eddie
by all means necessary and by all sorts
of strategies because it's kind of a our
survival is on the line and it's an
emergency and we're acting like it so I
have to fight like it's an emergency
like I'm fighting for my generations
lives because that's really what's
happening it's not just another issue on
the list not just another thing to be
concerned about its tied with everything
President Trump has put the economy
there at the heart of his presidency in
the heart of his campaign for
re-election and it's almost as if it's
the economy versus the environment in
the environment isn't going to win in
votes well that's false because first of
all how are you gonna have a functioning
economy in an unlivable planet with it's
just it's if you just think of it in
business which is it's bad business to
destroy life on Earth how are you going
to have business if you have
catastrophic climate disasters if you
have all the terrible effects of climate
change the uncertainty the instability
the violence that comes out of plunging
resources it's just simply bad business
plus it's proven that renewable energy
is a much more profitable market and
it's it's coming up to be a lot cheaper
than fossil fuels and it just it doesn't
make sense to say that we should
sacrifice all life on Earth for the
temporary wealth of businesses because
they don't want to change first of all
not only is that cruel and inhumane but
it's just not true it's not a choice
between
the environment or business it's either
we go down this road of just greed and
kill ourselves or we improve our planet
and improve businesses with newer
cleaner and better jobs because let's be
honest no one actually enjoys working in
a coal mine no one actually enjoys that
that is very dirty and hard work and so
renewable energy jobs are significantly
better so it just it's just completely
false and it's that narrative is really
just propaganda from the fossil fuel
industry as a scare tactic saying that
we can't save life on earth and we can't
care for people or animals or the
environment because they just want to
get rich and they're currently getting
rich off of oil gas and coal and they're
scared to change but it's not a choice
between the environment and the economy
that is one of the biggest myths ever
Jamie before we go I just want to ask
you about the situation in Oregon where
Republican senators have walked out of a
debate on the climate bill and looking
to limit carbon emissions by 2050 what
does that tell us about the state of
debate well there's there's just so much
climate denial right now in the United
States that it's it's very concerning
because a lot of times like these
politicians those who are walking out
those who are just completely closing
their eyes to the climate crisis these
politicians are really in the pockets of
the fossil fuel industry they get most
of their a lot of big chunks of their
campaign money from the fossil fuel
industry and so in turn they owe them
favors and so even though a lot of these
politicians I think personally know
better and personally know that the
climate crisis is a huge threat that
it's tied with everything and that it's
threatening life on Earth they are
pressured by these industries that are
funding their campaigns to do favors for
them so they will go out and vote
against policies knock down policies
obstruct any climate progress not
because they don't know better but
because they're there in the pockets of
these industries and until we can get
those industries out of our politics
it's going to be very hard to take
really urgent the radical action that we
need because
right now at least in the United States
and I know this isn't unique to the
United States a lot of politicians are
in the pockets of these industries and
kind of doing their bidding so that
means that they're not actually
representing the constituents the people
that they're supposed to be helping a
government's job is to protect young
people like me I'm only 17 years old I
in theory have a long and prosperous
life to look forward to but that's the
government's job to protect kids like me
and to protect people like me who do not
have any power but are just stuck in
this system and right now they are
choosing to they're choosing to put
profits over my life and the life of
children and it manifests into denialism
like that